don't hire coaches Corner proud to be
the exclusive tire the Dan Patrick show
no matter where you drive what you drive
how you drive continental designs tires
for what you do for more information
visit Continental Tire com Continental
Tire for what you do
he's Jim Boeheim Syracuse head coach
pulled off the surprise win against Duke
last night and your wife texting me late
night said there's no guarantee you'll
even be in a good mood today how are you
feeling today coach she knows me too
well unfortunately it's nice to get on
your show I only get out once a year to
once every two three years only win a
game but I appreciate it I know you're
busy I was listening to your show
talking about on what you were mean you
are right about Eagles I can't believe
you're right actually yeah they might as
well just keep both quarterbacks paying
the money and then when Lynch gets hurt
they got the other guy to going to
playoffs oh not bad not a bad idea
alright I help me with this how does a
team that loses to Buffalo Old Dominion
and Georgia Tech beat Duke a Duke forty
percent from the three instead of 22
he's always 703 games you know I mean we
wanted Ohio State we want a Notre Dame
we've actually been a better road team
this year at home but our point guard
was heard a lot early we got him back
and our Center who hits eight rebounds
in four games at 18 rebounds last night
so we were very fortunate with the way
those guys played obviously Duke's a
great team but they you know they lost
their point guard early redish didn't
play two great players but you know at
the road the other day against Florida
State Williamson didn't play in the
second half and they beat Florida State
pretty good team top top 1015 team so
they're still really good so it was a
good win for us but we did we we've
struggled shooting the ball this year
and we shot it really well we had a
veteran guard type battle take over the
game early and then we got contributions
from everybody but we know when our
center and our point guard played like
that we are good we can
a lot of teams and that was really the
difference in the game and and those two
guys especially trained Jones me and out
really hurts their defense O'Connell
came in and had 16 points was four of
eight from the three and he wouldn't
have been playing if tre Jones was there
but so they lose great defense but they
got somebody can make a bunch of threes
did you recruit Zion Williamson you know
we didn't he's just too big and strong
for us you know I didn't think he fit in
well with her 180 councils he weighs
more than two of our forwards I told I
feel bad because I don't all right I
told him erect if he comes down the
middle get in front of him and he got
here I think he was at the foul line and
he ended up in the first row of seats
and I'm like going why did I do that why
did I even say that the kid you know the
kids from Slovakia probably thought that
he's he's one of those you know he does
what the coaches says you know it's not
always if I told that to one of my other
guys did you tell that to your son he
weighs a hundred eight well he actually
is bigger than Meraki weighs 190 pounds
but I don't know I yeah to win a game
yeah I might tell him that I don't know
I don't know Mom I not mom might not
like that she would I wouldn't be able
to come home I mean I I could say that
job but I'd be in another place I'd be
at the quality or some place but you
know Williamson's Allah I mean he's
Karl's is probably mad at me because he
reminds me of Charles Barkley which
actually as a compliment to Charles I
who was obviously a great Hall of Fame
player but this kid is just like another
world another level of Charles Barkley
he's a little bigger and just mean so
stand he weighs 25 pounds weight 285
pounds but it wasn't distributed the
same way you know just for different
body you can I think was different
he's a different guy he's hard to play
against but I there's a little bit of
Rodney Rogers that I see with him yeah a
little bit of a voice much more talent
level of Barkley yeah I see that
everybody listen to the show doesn't
know who you were talking about it's
true either
yeah it's not the way but that's okay as
long as you even play that's all I was
pretty old but when you look at
Williamson with that body how does that
body look what's he gonna be like in the
in the NBA because guys add weight all
the time when they you know they're
going on and here he is as a freshman
how big can he still be great he's great
right now I don't think yesterday he'll
stay the same I don't think you know
probably I would imagine if he's smart
he'll lose a few pounds where is the NBA
he'll talk him down a little bit but
he'll have some troubles falling inside
over some of the NBA players but he's
just so physical and there's not as many
big guys and Anthony and anymore I mean
this guy we haven't seen a guy like him
you know I I've been here I've been
coaching a long time we played against a
lot of great players you know a lot of
great players I really I just haven't
seen anybody for me shoots the ball from
the three-point line he's he's a special
player everybody has said that but I've
seen a lot of people who say they're
like you they you know they don't know
that much about basketball so I mean
I've watched a lot of guys of course the
Olympic guys I've seen this guy seen
Patrick and Charles and those guys when
they were young I haven't seen anybody
like Scott he's he's something special
bear it's a great player you know Dukes
gonna be just fine they're they get
everybody back there they're still one
of the teams to beat I think Virginia is
special this year I think this is Tony
Bennett's best team they've got two or
three NBA players and I think they're
still that
to beat in the country I think they've
got the best chance of anybody I've seen
to win the national championship are you
hesitant to put the LeBron tag on Zion
because I'm curious at this stage of
their careers yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't
do that I would not do that I think he's
really really good but LeBron does so
many things he's a guard he's a point
guard he can play center if you have to
you can go hanging garden centers power
forwards he's the only guy I've seen
that really can defend five positions
people say those guys like that but he's
the only guy I've seen in defender five
positions and be the point guard and
make a three well I feel like Michaels a
little ahead of him he's right next door
it's in terms of the guys that I've
watched play did you recruit LeBron you
know it was he was gonna go it was
pretty much well said out of high school
so you know and it was not one of those
things to do if you had any thought of
going to college and if guys stayed
longer knowing I had one of their
friends going to probably try to get in
there but he was gonna go all the way
how was recruiting changed in the last
20 years it really it really hasn't I
mean everybody's a difference in college
basketball's everybody that you recruit
thinks they're gonna be in a year you
know I mean they don't realize there's
17 guys on a roster now in the NBA and
really only the top 6 7 8 10 players are
gonna make it in that league and the
rest are gonna be playing the jeely
you're trying to fight to go to Europe
or something there's just not enough
spots and up there anymore they can get
guys in the Z League but if it's not an
elite player an elite player is not
going to go the jeely so if a pretty
good player goes to the ceiling he's
never gonna get out of there to get up
to the end date because there's a
limited number of spots in places and
the one thing that I'm afraid of most
for young kids they get the message they
can go away
could the MBA out of high school they're
gonna stop still you know just gonna
prepare to go to the MBA and they're not
guy there's very few very very few guys
that can do that and go right to the MBA
college is still the best place for
young guys to go and they can learn and
they get better like draymond Green down
his problem and he had four years in the
program there's a lot of guys like that
they get four years at a good program
Malcolm Brogdon is a star now in the NBA
four years at Virginia it really made
him into a player you know we'll see
what happens down the road but you know
we just got to prepare Pittsburgh we got
them Saturday they're pick lastly they
before to say by 13 points so this
league is difficult as is all of college
basketball there's a lot of good players
and for today I'm on ok coach but that
can change by Saturday night just to
recap what you said last night after the
win he's hard to handle it's hard to
defend him Sian Williamson he's a
physical specimen he's like Charles
Barkley was except he shoots better than
Charles did and he's not as fat yes
Charles Barkley is actually on the line
right now hey Charles when I see you I'm
gonna say to you Jim please take your
glasses off so you can't punch a man
with glasses on that's wrong you just
have to put your finger on me plus
pounds 70 put your finger on me but how
about I compare the greatest young
player a long time to you and I mean as
an equal type of comparison as a player
so that's a compliment
I had to put aback a little negative in
there as well I'm not
I'm not sensitive at all I go what the
kid is really bullying also it's been
fun to watch him play oh my gosh yeah
but he got a unbelievable body but I
think he's a lot more explosive than me
to be honest with you well you are
pretty explosive Charles going I'm not
gonna sell you short I think they'll do
yours people don't realize you're six
for this guy 67 or so you know so that
was gonna be my question for you like I
have a better man person is he really
sick 7 I think he's a shade under if you
know I would say I would say but is with
you I don't think that matters that
whether he's six six six
he plays bigger I remember when you
don't I think at the Olympic Trials we
don't want to talk about but I remember
when you dumped on Patrick and dry lane
and another 7-footer remember that you
tore the basket down in the building all
stop and yeah we call those the good old
days that's you know somebody in my
house is from Alabama said Charles and
Wade is all in his but I didn't say that
I never say that but okay so Jim's wife
is the one who said that and that's
who's in the background there yes he's
always telling me what to say and that's
a and there's no argument about thanks
Charles
you're right this kid is I mean you're
gonna enjoy watching this kid play in
the NBA I'm glad there's a one-and-done
rule right now
which was a zero indent rule but yeah
he's special he he'll have some problems
with size once in a while but he'll just
knock guys out of the way and get to the
basket but yeah he's he's gonna be fun
to watch over the next 10 15 years hey
Charles thanks for being a good sport
answering the phone I don't know if you
knew what was going to be brought up
when we brought you on here with the
coach behind but thanks for being a good
sport
oh man any time thank you for having me
Tara tennis I hello Jim you know I love
you back happy I'll see you at you I see
you and Julie somewhere Thank You
Charles and coach congratulations on the
win and thanks for joining us tell your
wife you know let's wait until the next
big win before she texts me at like 2:00
in the morning thank you thank you
that's Jim Boeheim Continental Tire
Coaches Corner and Charles Barkley
Continental Tire proud to be the
exclusive tire of the Dan Patrick show
no matter where you drive how you drive
what you drive they have a tire for you
good job Fritzi tracking down Berkeley
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]